yo yo yo this is over here with Miriam
and Zach
good to be here it's good to be with you
guys we also have Alan on on audio
what's up everyone and we are hanging
out being visionary and stuff stuff so
much stuff okay what do you say to that
Zak let's do it
Alan yeah
beautiful co-creating something real yes
so
[Music]
yeah
what if our pace has is starting out
slow
literally right now yeah well that would
be a change of pace because usually
things are pretty quick or rushed is it
bad to have a slow pace not what I'm
used to
yeah maybe I'm not used to that either
unless I forced myself I think I think
movies go too slow I think that movie
should go at the speed of Twitter for me
to stay engaged is that why you fall
asleep yeah I usually just like
fast-forward to a movie yeah yeah don't
even watch it just like season slides I
got it how about details I'm very
detail-oriented so I like to like put
the captions on I know I know you really
do tell you're like this is giving
cinematic you read half as fast as I do
if you're consciously and also there's
my eyesight is compromised I skip every
other word yeah yeah I was taught speed
reading but but I really wanted to take
in the details
yeah my friend will was like how are you
able to speed read and I'm just like oh
I just tossed comprehension out the
window he said we mean I'm like I have
no idea what I read I just scanning for
keywords I wish I could just touch a
book and just have it like by osmosis
like into your brain right
I wish yeah I would do that all day long
right just absorb knowledge do you ill
happen one day you'll just have to you
know put in a neuro chip like a neuro
lace into your brain yeah and is that
something you're going to do in order to
speed read and comprehend fast
I believe I even said it in the segment
with
and that if I could I would put a chip I
just wouldn't guys guys guys I thought I
was like that facilitating sorry we just
ran with it go ahead you feel feel
freedom come house swinging spiritual
MMA so well but then again I might just
makes us all slow we can take a step and
take a breather and and between us three
create a resonance where you know the
little faster and we move a little
slower I'm down for that
okay let's see how we do okay are you
down sure all right whoa what about you
Alan super downs all right cool do you
have a question so you're the leader now
Emily I mean you have that dynamic
Shakti Shakti you know I'm saying well
let's give us a topic all right
oh you're interested in for us to
explore in this gangsta session okay is
it worth living
with devotion would you like to go ahead
devotion is attachment to purpose an
attachment is the link to all suffering
is that what you told me you told me so
um I think that's a universal law I
don't think it comes from me
we'll have to say non attachment well if
you're devoted that's a spiritual
attachment it isn't the attachment the
cause of all suffering yeah so yeah but
if you just free yourself before being
devotional before flowering that facet
then what about the people meaning we
should have a devotion for a greater
good that extends beyond us the waiter
said yeah well I would agree
we definitely have devotion and purpose
which I now know is the word Akagi in
Japanese great so what do you say that
what I see it at what do you say to that
well zach is devoted I'm devoted yeah
and I'm [ __ ] miserable okay are we
just dreaming life yeah you know you can
swear it all you want okay good we went
over those ground rules first episodes
dude my devotion has been the source of
like all of my angst like it's caused me
to lose friends and lose family
it looks pretty specific context but the
return on investment has been higher
consciousness and a higher vibrational
energy that resonates with the prime
creator
someone once said devotion is the
sweetest way to be is that a big pun no
we were talking about bees earlier and
they are devoted to the greater good and
to the - to being selfless yeah how do
you cultivate devotion the question
itself was devotional okay um how do you
cultivate devotion
is it inmate is it something you can do
in every facet of your life
like if I'm dressing I'm devoted to the
act like or iam or a grater that's so I
guess from one perspective kid devotion
is like involved miss right whatever
you're involved in you're devoting
yourself to it and so perhaps there are
levels of devotions and there are higher
and lower expressions of devotion
absolutely sure and all the skin in the
game or your how fast are you willing
are you willing to I guess prover bleed
I for your purpose but obviously would
say someone like Zack you know taking
having courage and consciousness to
leave a sweet convenient life of free
massages and everything so he's
courageous absolutely hmm that's my
favorite my favorite emotion like
devotion and courage are like my
favorite who would you say embodies for
you both Martin Luther King okay who
ended up dying for what he believes in
yeah and then there's like you know like
Jesus Christ and like there's all these
figures that everyone always names but
man those facets now we're in 2019 and
smaller things than those stories happen
right even just hanging out with some
quote-unquote friends but then you have
these collective energies of separation
and hatred and survival and fear that
arise in virtually most social settings
and so there's still an arena for us to
be
these heroes these embodiments of truth
these courageous devotional beings
anywhere although i don't think that if
you're if you are devotional you're
doing it to be a hero hopefully you're
not doing it for the fame or else ego
creeps in you're just
it's your purpose and you're motivated
by that and you have no kind of choice
in a sense like you can say again let's
say taking zack as an example like it
was probably not going to speak for you
but eating you alive to continue to live
a lie carrying the truth yeah I had to
do it and if I didn't the badge feels
would continue don't want those bags you
don't want to yell that feels that's
simple as I can put it and think in my
case almost dying losing my life and
wanting to be of service and do
something that's bigger than me
something to give back I mean and for
some people that's having a child or a
family every you know everybody it's
different because obviously being a
parent is a big sacrifice yes for sure
but it's individual to find your purpose
or your own devotion it could be devoted
to making the you know baddest the
badass like meal for the night or
something everything here at a
devotional act yeah which also takes
presence which is difficult in our day
haha yes yeah
what are you devoted to worry I'm
devoted to
I'm devoted to
I'm devoted to flowering yeah as a human
being I mean flying your your spirit as
a human being and as a species yeah
flowering like you know what I'm saying
do you think that as a society we are
flowering right now it's funny because
my society is so it feels like I love
how you talked about this that small
small ending the scale of devotion like
when you cook or what like even like
when you pick up the water from your
bedside or like when you like tap
somewhat like you can just make it
smaller but that's still you're still
creating your reality and I do feel that
in my experience over time that my earth
my whole reality the whole world is
sweeter and you could say it's because I
don't happen to come across this news
story or this tournament but that's my
experience well that brings up that
there is a sense of maybe five
personally if I wasn't a journalist
maybe I wouldn't be well I don't watch
to me or read mainstream garbage BS news
but there is a sense of like if you go
off to the jungle and you're just
connecting with nature and you're going
within and not partaking in the matrix
you know there's there's some joy in
that yeah but then there's also wanting
to be part of this revolution that's
happening and be on the forefront of the
wave the phase transition
go from point A and now we're going to
like me yeah and it's happening now but
it's about me there's a big awakening a
quickening that's happening wanting to
be part of a community of other truth
seekers and that's devotional beautiful
beautiful the next world it's a brave
new world a higher density of light in
the dreamscape if there is such a thing
I believe there's a dreamscape same or
onward magic you can you can manifest
magic you can manifest your dreams and
part of that is believing and focusing
your energy into positivity and saying
that after kind of being taken down a
rabbit hole of negativity watching
what's happening what do you guys want
to ask me now ask you what I asked what
did you eat for breakfast Olli not the
healthiest thing well you're with the
food Nazis so I can say the word Nazi in
this day I had I was his challenges got
canceled intact Nazis are very sensitive
about all right just for that you're
sharing your breakfast first
what did we have uh it was a smorgasbord
of
not her and we also had I had a some
slices of organic turkey bed then I had
blueberries and then Athenian beautiful
mean that macadamia nuts and then some
water and some water and then when I go
back home I'm going to make myself a
smoothie with a bunch of fresh arugula
that I've frozen the best of other
frozen down that this guy ain't playing
around you cured all my problems by diet
nice food is that medicine oh nice
I'd like to say this started with
bulletproof coffee that was a little bit
too strong and didn't have enough butter
in it and finished my butter I put
butter and collagen in my bulletproof
coffee now it's your turn
what did you eat well those rice
krispies those special k uh-huh well
shows you thank you all right look maybe
I may have had Safeway deli chicken
wings of four varieties Wow
and some chocolate malt balls but but it
was after like a 27-hour fast way to
break your capacity 27 hours straight to
the malt balls and the chicken for
variety and I lied to you no please
don't
what does it mean for variety well they
had Buffalo barbeque teriyaki and fried
chicken wings yeah yeah how would you
eat that balls not mothballs not to be
confused with mothballs did you see down
up with my giant glass of milk no okay
just water okay together or did was
there some did you digest the chicken
wings and then have the mothballs
well why do you care what do you mean
that's the question that I chose to ask
as a food not seen and and functional
medicine consult well what if my real
sustenance
yes the thing that beats my heart and
sustains my physiology well is processed
food with all the nutrients removed no
not that what it's spirituality okay but
you're diverting from the mothballs and
the chicken wings yeah why first of all
why did you have a 27-hour fast and
break it with crap food what is this an
interrogation
well we're materialists the spirituality
is built on a foundation of healthy
eating yeah well I think you might be
more of a Gnostic with the spiritual
world telling first the material world
coming second it wasn't always this way
but that I would say that is the case so
but why did you have the fast was it
well to tell you the truth I have
unless my environment is like really
really supportive which hopefully it's
moving there yeah I have trouble with
most foods you know it's just like this
dense the world and you have this gut
with like all these parts and my first
couple two decades weren't perfectly you
know supported and so and so these days
sometimes I'll like fasting feels more
best thing is great it's good for your
sister if yeah it's good for your system
and but I fasted for like a couple of
weeks ago Palin was like or you need to
be fascinating I'm all but always
fascinating and like and like and you
could afford to fast probably and so I
took it on and I ended up fasting for a
hundred twenty seven hours and my
previous like just swatting yeah so
that's so it's really easy once you get
in today too doesn't it
first days a little bit hard
yeah yeah especially if you're on
carbohydrate metabolism as opposed to
burning ketones right yeah all right but
but then the the mystery is to break the
fast and then wear them all
did you go to the moth balls did you
seek them out at like Trader Joe's or
something so I tell you the truth I just
went to Safeway oh yes I think and it
was like you were [ __ ] hungry yeah I
was [ __ ] hungry and I was like in one
of those moods or it's like I'm gonna
try to just like buy exactly what like
my craving is as opposed to like a
health paradigm you know I was like I'm
enjoying it like just like really trust
my whatever I can say that to say
something to that yeah that there is the
I guess mindset of like Oh trust your
cravings but that in a lot of cases the
cravings are being controlled by like an
addiction to sugar mmm and that is
arguably an epidemic of sugar addiction
yeah like your cells are screaming
because their glycogen levels are low
and so they're like please give me some
sugar so I can build up my glycogen
stores and you basically got to make
your cells your [ __ ] just know right
that's our population come back on fat
and protein and lots and lots of leafy
vegetables yeah actually moderate
protein lots of funds but it is a habit
a habit that and it's a
diction I mean just yesterday at the
grocery store just like why are you
putting sugar in in smoked salmon right
what why are you putting sugar in the
bacon yeah because it's I think a
programmable matter that dom's people
down and makes them suggestible okay
before right before I did my thing where
I disclosed Google I had to purify
myself and so I had to change my diet
and I went to a really hardcore diet and
I started up staying abstaining from all
the vices that I had because in order to
have like a clear mind I needed to have
a clear body you know it's almost if one
is built on top its your temple yeah
it's the temple yeah the temple of I'm
not gonna say you know I'm gonna say cuz
we're telepathic like that but it's true
Auri
food is thy medicine or food is thy foe
so that's why I asked that question cuz
I mean you know what's interesting tell
me I literally feel yes more conscious
of my chubby cheeks okay now than five
minutes ago well I showed you we're not
talking about your chubby cheeks we're
talking about breaking your fast with
malt balls and what was it serious
looking like chicken wings four
different varieties of chicken wings and
I showed you mine sorry I showed you my
before now do you think that hierarchies
play a role in our metabolic processes
how are you defining higher
hierarchies like what the queen of does
the Queen of England have an impact on
my metabolic process Queen highway
honest what Queen is England what Queen
is England thing what do you mean by
that question it's a little bit of a
riddle can you decipher well so you
understand the question
queen is England no I have this
unexpected conjugation hey-oh explain
ory what yeah okay sorry I have an
answer yes from the point of view of
epigenetics if you're talking about the
hierarchies or the environment that are
controlling the world and causing this
stress then it does have an impact on
our metabolic processes because if
you're an epigenetic s-- is how our
environment can have an impact on our
genetic expressions and we are not
victims to our genes it's good to know
these polymorphisms that stand in the
way but you're not a victim to them yes
so it's time to get rid of the Queen
nope she's almost there
great I'm not wishing death to the Queen
just clear but I'm 9 so this speaks to
another interesting topic well how are
you going for you imagine close your
eyes imagine you're at the bottom of it
No oh you look up and you see a thousand
white stairs and for hours you're
climbing up these stairs and you start
to see a figure at the top of these
stairs and as you finally stairs to the
top you realize that it's a why is
Chinese man sitting cross-legged with
their really long beard as you get
closer you realize the beard is red
because it's eating Cheetos waiting
you're as we learned with speak food
why just nose was big food yeah Donna
said that Cheetos was originally big
food which I believe and why would in
the beard be orange because she knows
like if this Judas is orange it's orange
orange isn't that what his spirit isn't
the color orange
he said that was literally what I was
thinking like what if I came and like
like he was like eating Cheetos with
like chopsticks right yeah but that's
about way to eat Cheetos hey-oh use
chopsticks on anything I like eating
children chopsticks for my hands okay
I'll give you some okay let's see what
you got dumplings no I won't eat
dumplings guys do you think that we
could be even more yes I disagree
are we the next Joe Rogan experience
maybe Joe slogan haha that was rude she
actually loves my jokes right other
people just defend me oh that's good
just Joe slogan this is good what's the
next question because I can ask
questions all day long that's the
journalist well who's the sage here who
is the sage there's different versions
of sage Ness right on the competition no
I just love that word yes sage is a good
word so I'll go first okay anything in
the universe
what would you like to know
if I'm asking you say jewelry yeah
Ori Ori sorry apologize like Oreo or eat
there you go
I don't know that I want to ask anything
why did they call them apartment Who am
I recall Who am I gather to call myself
a sage blasphemous yes that's a mystical
one selfless agent arrogant and you get
to it's a mental health issue and
deluded and arrogant if you know what I
know that I have wisdom that is that why
I love it why is that arrogant yes I are
gay I'm owning it yeah are you tall yeah
how dare you say that no that's all fine
right you're tall you're a sage if you
speak it then you start to manifest it
especially if you know that you're not
saying it because of ego you think that
the CEO is the worst well there's
there's I think there's healthy ego I
mean we need a go yeah
then there's the it yeah it's just as
long as the ego is kept in check
uh-oh check check yeah don't don't
forget that Jeffrey Epstein in it comes
exactly I forgot to slip that one in and
let's talk about that for a second who
believes and there are people who
believe that he killed himself with
paper sheets and it's just coincidental
that it must have been like double ply
at least at least at least double ply
and that the cameras didn't work they
just went on and there was no reason to
kill him and kill all the see I just saw
you doing this with your fingers and I
make it mean that we're baking bread
here yeah okay
breaking bread though or baking bread
baking yeah
this means baking bread yeah yeah I
didn't know that this means baking bread
I thought this means it's all about the
money
same thing but it's a teaching it's a
we're doing it this is gangsta our yeah
so so what what would you want to know I
pass on that question I already have
enough psychic skills or in what do you
want Ori Ori what
you want what do I want I want
the tide of my life to continue rising
like tsunami style ah and always okay
there's a cryptic but alright what I'm
spiritual but bringing forth something
something
worthwhile absolutely meaningful are you
open to altering your diet yeah that's
good to hear
so the first thing I wanted to create a
show called clean up your life where I
would ransack someone's pantry or fridge
or medicine cabinet and just check out
all the toxic [ __ ] mmm so I would say
you don't have to say that about me well
I'm in your home so like for instance
the Special K would be something I would
trash yeah okay is actually not that
special it's actually mediocre and it
says on the box yeah don't be fooled by
the words by the way by the way one
thing that arose for me
as you shared that
was in addition to the pain that's
moving through you in processing is
how's Alan do it fantastic
any comments I love the flowering as a
myself and the species love that part it
was so good more of us viewed ourselves
as flowering that way I'd be incredible
I also love devotion and courage why did
you bring up the word pain because I
felt like you were just speaking
it felt like
you were moved when you were sharing
okay
or is that pain coming well in that
particular case be you and there are
levels and facets same or same or okay I
find that it's painful to watch others
eat Kaka food because I know that they
can awaken or increase their brain
cognitive skills or excel in the way
that their body operates and I also know
that the big corporations are poisoning
us and so I feel indignant in the sense
of like how dare you poison me
but even say it's about wide it's also
your potentials being held back right
like you are a flowering flower and but
the flower is not at its full potential
because instead of water you chose
coca-cola to put the flower in
right maybe a little viagra and that
coca-cola too you know
cuz that actually makes the flower like
blooms stronger this is true did you
know this no turns out they put viagra
in some of the like plantain --ax yeah
was it supposed to be a fertilizer that
no one makes it makes the plant like
good stiffer bloom harder well I'm
saying that because there's lots of
things that were meant for other things
and then find their way in the food
supply like you know they use a yoga mat
ingredient in bread or they put they
sneak in a lot of poisons in the food
and that impacts IQ points and impacts
again you know clogs up and creates
metabolic syndrome which is inflammation
which is oxidative stress which is
insulin resistance as you can't reach
those higher vibrational levels unless
you build it on a foundation health and
that health is conditioned
and let's say having devotion if you
know that those chicken wings are
actually pumped up with hormones and
antibiotics that are harming you so how
the devotion to your body temple-like
think of that animal and all the
suffering it had in its life not that
you're responsible for that suffering
but by eating that animal you are taking
all its suffering in a concentrated form
and proving that into but sure you're
not dissing you're not like a beacon
you're just dissing conventional farming
where there's torture what I choose
food that minimizes suffering like if
the animal had a good life for you
pasture range you know chicken like you
know eating grain then you're not taking
in concentrated suffering the stress and
stress right and torture yeah right I
have a I have a friend that's a
fruitarian he eats 30 bananas a day he's
like I call him mr. bananas
but I don't think he knows that and he's
he's invited me to try just eating
fruits which I would if I was in the
jungle and there's a different climate
but did not take in that death energy
yeah no death energy only eat chicken
that's been raised on Prozac yeah they
actually do give pets Prozac that's
pretty crazy to give you a cat Prozac
Wow I know no in the gave her cat Prozac
and now I just learned that an animal
had IBS oh it won't bow son girl yeah
her cat had an IBS huh related to prozac
or just just really probably to eating
shitty pet food probably well that has
grains and that was on a grain free can
I ask you something Chris did you just
use the S word you just got another
strike well weird
yeah I thought that swearing was loud is
it offensive to your devotion well I
mean why do I swear
yeah I have a potty mouth right now she
does it she tries to text me and there's
all these words that are like censored
like the phone censoring it right it's a
new things new things any things all
just taking a lot they're censoring us
in so many ways why do I swear well yeah
why do you swear it's it's uh emphasis
you need to stop just stop it that
sounds like my mama I hear her voice
many times I'm gonna imitate her meaty
why do you say the f-word it sounds so
vulgar meaning can't you stop if it's my
mom self but I would like to take the
opportunity to break and unpack the f
uck word do you know where the word [ __ ]
comes from find under carnal knowledge
so the prostitutes when they became
prostitutes because at one point they
were courtesans and they were healing
through sex they started giving to me
giving them fines and putting a stamp f
uck
so just to break down there's also a
study that shows that people who swear
are more intelligent look it up not also
more trustworthy
yes this is true and I do try to curb my
swing but Alan said that we could swear
this is like party pretty on well but I
respect if someone's offended I won't
say bad words
if you're a flower that's blooming what
kind of flower with that yeah it's good
question
there's many flowers if I'm a flower
that's blooming what kind of flower
would that be yes
reflexively as soon as you articulated
that was like the flower okay
the flower and what is the flower is
there the flower is there an emblematic
flower of all flowers I think so or at
least uh yeah
what comes to mind without thinking just
like what's the Flitz your flower will
you see in your mind's eye
well with you guys know what's your
flower just like don't think about it
what flower did you see yeah
I saw my glory
that's all Gerber Daisy well when I look
at you I see a light above your head
okay you don't have to know what kind of
do you see auras huh
you see his aura I don't I also see a
light close to your head
so
[Music]
the
[Music]
who are doing it you don't want to
answer the question
so that's like chanting
the deathless flower the indestructible
eternal expressive
their grades
Eirik
have you heard of the book flowers in
the Attic
no have you Alan no but I love your
answer deathless eternal indestructible
I have not
it's a classic book that I grew up in my
cousin much older than you huh that's
true and it's about a brother and sister
that are there's a whole series and they
are locked up in the attic and they are
the flowers that somehow managed not to
wither but do form an incestuous
relationship
it's a classic book sounds more like a
deflower quantity flowering an
incestuous one but hey they were stuck
in the Attic maybe there was more than
two maybe they had siblings
anyway the series goes all through until
they're freed from the Attic look it's a
symbolic are you serious
I am very serious yep I was a bookworm
read a lot of books growing up I was a
nerd proud nerd a chubby nerd
gray yeah wasn't so great when you know
called you fatso or tub of lard that's
the worst thing they were called tub of
lard
it's pretty pretty ugly this the worst
thing was five-years-old
recess cold I have a crush on this boy
named Peter and someone brings it says
like Oh Mary has a crush on Peter and
then he says but me I'm so fat she can
roll around the world and obviously show
me a picture because I want to see what
this looks like
no I was never a super was just chubby
not fat enough to roll around the world
but I guess fat enough to not have Peter
as her scarf her gravitational pull yeah
I grew up on the eating not mothballs
but McDonald's and Coca Cola and Doritos
and lots of junk food
damn damn and now your treasure from
that trauma again I've done it's to a
gun show gun show I'm a lot of no one's
taking her Second Amendment rights
no nope so food yeah
has a big role and being picked on as a
child stays with you obviously
I formed bulimia like many young women
are you pointing at me cuz you're the
host I'm also looking at Zach well can
you just own it as your own
I mean you don't gotta wield your
energies at me okay I didn't know I was
wielding my energy it's a pull back my
Shakti power I will not look at you
worry no I own it
not on my chubbiness you're not chubby
no I was I'm talking over the past we're
talking in the power of food on the mind
and the body
great great
so let's shall we talk about something
else
I just really like having you here like
I feel more like this sage I want to be
with you like being dynamic and shining
thank you so if you lie feel it makes me
feel good even though I'm wielding my
power at you yeah just looking at you
yeah I contact my present yes
should we talk about censorship
or can we talk about censorship with
Eames of different vibrational energy so
true was I thinking there's no space for
a censorship in this sacred space we've
created okay
some time off feels right now feels yes
her ship is um oppressive and very
material material wrong he's in
spiritual
okay channeling powerful Gnostic energy
yes blang blang the same promising
blossoming flowers that are deathless
yes
is there another topic we can explore
yeah
and wrap on since it's gangsta sure I
was gonna say Zach but to rap on
yeah
what do we want to yeah we can do that
what do we want to create with this
video if we're being intentional
[Laughter]
I don't know what do we want to create
well I like more personally having a
theme to be able to oops build on so
that there's a takeaway for the audience
mm okay how about what does it actually
mean to be deathless in the flesh well I
would say one knowing that your eternal
spirit that is beyond this bodysuit and
you can also be deathless in that you
can leave a legacy behind whether that's
a kid or a book or a movement or some
type of signature something that's
greater than you that lives on thank you
I think of deathless as people will
never stop saying your name but not in a
it go equate
in any such way to the bonding Infini
then you are dead less or eternal very
nice the next question
okay what's the purpose of having a name
is the seed
of our persona
see Doris ona yes and many people change
their names
it's a sappy sounding names like like
Vishnu ohm
when the real name is George so people
can sometimes rename themselves I guess
it's a way to an identifier or hopefully
your name has some meaning like there
was a reason why your parents named you
the name that they named you well my
name is Ori
which means for I right yeah which means
light I love it
how about you guys it means like yeah it
means my light in Hebrew my family is
Israeli I use daily okay the Zachary I
sent you a whole think about what your
name means it's quite splendid which is
something I send its you on Twitter
recently no a lot of time ago
no yeah like two months ago no that's
right you did no I was like maybe two
and a half weeks ago No
look at well I'll let you know that were
first dating right know as a first
argument
so Zachary was the name of an angel what
what did you discover about I discovered
that it's Zachary not is Zachary that
Zachary is to be in the presence of the
Zachary makes the other person feel like
the most beautiful person this is what
the what my findings were and that
person has a lot of love but I don't
know that ain't I don't know that do you
know that you should know what Zachary
the angel is all about it's just a label
Zachary the angel yeah I mean it's like
well it's just a name well let's not get
too fluffy here you know I mean this is
simulation talking to you alright -
fluffy I mean let's be sensitive to our
viewers I mean we're talking about some
dance like science e-business II
entrepreneurship II and stuff cool you
know what I'm saying
sure then ask let's ask a question in
spiritual how can we make sure they like
us you know I don't think we can make
sure we can just be authentic if they
don't like us they can change the
channel
oh snap
that's why it's gangster
cool okay next question that's more
business C all right I know he was
really facilitating his you said more
business II know I'm taking your your
cute
you said let's address the audience that
is entrepreneurial and business C so
yeah we can can definitely address such
a topic are we in a simulation or is
this the real reality oh yeah
I say simulation
I say simulation
or whatever you want to call it right
how about you simulation
with some little glitches here and there
totally I believe are in the real world
uh like channeling our viewers real
world okay in this very moment because
I'm real okay Zack is holding down the
realness space yeah he's representing
and anchoring that he's the real guru
you guys all think your Sims or
something no I think I'm in a sim I
don't think I'm assume I was meaning
like the game yeah I guess invoicing bah
bah bah bah bah I just have I have other
voices
that's wonk wonk it's not one of them
okay British voice retrace the Marg
voice okay then the furnace stimulation
what's the real form of reality capital
N
got confused there what the capital n
was yeah nature their real form of
reality well one time I was sleeping and
I've had some like really cool sleep
experiences multiple which probably make
good answer different facets of that but
one the first one that came to mind was
I was sleeping and I woke up in my sleep
but not to this simulation I woke up to
myself falling I was in this like
infinite blackness blacker than black
the good is like is like a quality the
closest thing would be black but and I
didn't know and it was very short this
awakening and I only remembered it it
was in my sleep I woke up and there's
like this let's say 15 seconds and then
I remember the middle of the next day
what nice but it's all black black and
and I'm like falling like I I couldn't
have my bearings like I didn't know how
to be in this round in this but it was
so real and it was very clear I was
super lucid it was like oh this is me
like it didn't feel any different than
this or any normal day it's like dude
I'm worried except I'm not like you know
like I'm I'm actually like just this
like just this like eyeballs in this
like vastness of black this
groundless like indescribable vastness
and yeah that was so maybe that and then
yeah and then maybe there are other
facets that are more bright and stuff
anyway so this is we touched upon dreams
what do you get your name so do you have
a reoccurring dream or a dream that
stands out Zach yeah when I'm falling
off of a cliff and then right before I
hit the cliff I wake up
is that a reoccurring dream yeah my
reoccurring dream is I can see myself
behind driving and I'm remotely trying
to control the car that's about to crash
and I don't have control of the brakes
and it's a reoccurring dream that's
happened over and over
where I'm trying to control the car and
then wake up before it smashes into
another car I used to have also dreams
where there used to be a gathering of us
and there was a cliff and we used to
just practice flying those are [ __ ]
fun flying like a lucid dream where you
can like control the dream as of late
yes I don't know if I'm controlling it
I'm just awake and I'm realizing that
I'm also dreaming why implying I can
control where I go I wish I had more of
those lucid that's a practice do you do
that yes sometimes umm the earth fall in
love with someone in your dream that
you've never met before I've had dreams
of someone else that I don't know but I
don't know them so I guess yes I've had
a sleep gasm just waking up having a
noise are you guys enlightened
enlightened maybe on some things not not
all things
it's many layers for enlightened I don't
think could be on this earth plane
I feel like I resonate with the with
divine energy but am i itself a source
of a of enlightenment and illumination
maybe yeah sure yeah sounds good are you
which part of me I feel like a vessel I
feel like a vessel and I feel like my
nature is very about in light like it's
very enlightening II that's how I feel
like you're a catalyst for others to
reach enlightenment yeah yeah that's
beautiful
yeah thank you I think it's important
for us to shine our light yes and that's
infectious eliminate the darkness
yeah Illuminati the darkness maybe
there's one on the dance floor the first
one on the dance floor yeah high five
you guys yes
I'm often the first one on the dance
floor
Oh what was that joke dance like
everyone's watching no it's not a joke
but dance like nobody's watching and
learning out the Joe those a joke we
sell oh yeah yeah at the Comedy Store
but it was not about dancing they made
it something else that I don't remember
okay do you remember I remember that was
really funny
stupidly Friday better that's gonna be a
cliff here cuz I don't know the punch
line or that or anything that precedes
it no but yeah dance like nobody's
watching
yeah we have to go along with that yeah
it's like that's why I closed my eyes on
the dance floor me too it closed - mmhmm
yeah because then when I open up I'm
like oh my god we're watching me and
then I'm super embarrassed really yeah
but you're such a great dancer
[Music]
it's okay I'm owning my that I know I'm
a good dancer too
yeah let's wrap something get your ass
home okay It's A Wrap
okay all right well Alan has spoken
it's great to be with you guys tonight
really it was fun and thanks to all our
viewers for tuning in and as Alan would
say like comment and stuff and and we'll
see you soon have a good one almost
there
not much day what we ran out